sea de x igual a 1 entre x esto es
importante
podemos usar el teorema del valor medio
para decir que la ecuación g prima de x
igual a un medio tiene una solución
donde menos 1 es menor que x menor que 2
de ser así
escribe una justificación pausa el vídeo
e inténtalo
la clave para usar el teorema del valor
medio incluso antes de pensar en usarlo
es estar seguros de que tenemos una
función continua en un intervalo cerrado
y diferenciable en un intervalo abierto
aquí tenemos el intervalo abierto y el
intervalo cerrado incluirá los puntos
extremos este de aquí sin embargo puedes
darte cuenta de inmediato de que ambos
intervalos contienen al 0 a x igual a 0
x igual a cero la función es definida es
la función es definida allí entonces no
tendremos una función continua o
diferenciable en ese punto por lo tanto
podemos escribir que no
la función no es continua o
diferenciable en el intervalo la función
no es continua o diferenciable en el
intervalo
bien leamos la segunda pregunta podemos
usar el teorema del valor medium para
decir que existe un valor ser tal que se
prima de ser es igual a menos un medio y
uno es menor que sea menor que dos de
ser así escribe una justificación bueno
pausa de nuevo el vídeo
bien en esta ocasión tenemos el
intervalo entre 1 y 2 en ambos casos en
el intervalo cerrado y en el intervalo
abierto y esta de aquí es una función
racional y una función racional será
continua y diferenciable en todos los
puntos de su dominio y su dominio
contiene completamente este intervalo
abierto y también el cerrado otra forma
de pensarlo es que cada uno de los
puntos de este intervalo abierto y del
intervalo cerrado está en el dominio de
esta función así que vamos a escribirlo
vamos a escribir que gtx es una función
racional
gtx es una función racional lo que nos
hace saber que la función es continua y
diferenciable en cada punto de su
dominio el intervalo cerrado de 1 a 2
están en su dominio
ahora bien vamos a ver cuál es la tasa
de cambio promedio de 1 a 2
tenemos que g de 2 - g de 1 esto entre 2
- 1
va a ser igual a bueno de todos es un
medio
medio menos uno
entre dos menos uno que es uno y esto es
lo mismo que menos uno
en medio de lo que se sigue que por el
teorema del valor medio existe al menos
una c donde se está entre 1 y 2 y déjeme
bajar un poco la pantalla y terminemos
de resolverlo
y mi primer deseo es decir la tasa de
cambio promedio entre los puntos
extremos del intervalo esto es igual a
menos un medio y lo hemos logrado
podemos escribir que en efecto si
podemos usar el teorema del valor médium
para decir que existe este valor se tal
que ge prima de sem es igual a menos un
medio y esta es nuestra justificación
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo